IF HE DOES NOT WIN, THE
REPUBLICANS CAN'T WIN THE
SENATE.
LET'S DO SOMETHING I SWORE I
WOULDN'T DO.
I AM GOING TO DO A WHAT ABOUTISM
AS IT RELATES TO PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND DONALD TRUMP.
LISTENING TO BIDEN'S WORDS AND
WATCHING HIS ACTIONS, I FEEL I
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
WHAT ABOUT IF DONALD TRUMP HAD
GIVEN A MAJOR U.N. SPEECH AND
STOPPED SHORT WITH WHAT TO DO
NEXT.
WE ALL KNOW HOW THE MEDIA WOULD
REACT.
BUT NOT A WORD ABOUT THAT
STUTTERING WORD.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, FOUR DAYS OF
THE DEADLY HURRICANE AS IT MAKES
LANDFALL, HE KEPT HIS DATE FOR A
PARTY FUNDRAISER AT WHICH TIME
HE RIPPED THAT GOVERNOR AND
OTHER REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS
INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE
SITUATION ROOM, PUTTING ON THE
WIND BREAKER AND MAKING SOME
DECISIONS.
WE ALL KNOW TRUE LEADERS ARE
DEFINED BY HOW THEY REACT TO
DISASTERS.
NOW BACK TO THE WHAT ABOUTISMS.
WHAT IF MIKE PENCE SAID, NORTH
KOREA.
>> THE UNITED STATES SHARES A
VERY IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP
WHICH IS AN ALLIANCE WITH THE
REPUBLIC OF NORTH KOREA.
IT'S AN ALLIANCE THAT IS STRONG
AND ENDURING.
>> UNCORRECTED AND THEY CHANGED
THE TRANSCRIPT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP
FORGOT A CONGRESSWOMAN HE
EULOGIZED WAS IN FACT DEAD.
>> SENATOR VAUGHN, SENATOR
BOOKER, REPRESENTATIVE JOOKY --
WHERE IS JACKIE?
I THOUGHT SHE WAS GOING TO BE
HERE.
BRIAN: WHAT IF A REPUBLICAN
PRESS SECRETARY DIDN'T HAVE A
GOOD ANSWER FOR THAT STUNNING,
SHOCKING STATEMENT.
>> SHE WAS ON HIS MIND, SHE WAS
TOP OF MIND FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE LOOKS FORWARD TO DISCUSSING
HER REMARKABLE LEGACY OF PUBLIC
SERVICE WHEN HE SEES HER FAMILY
THIS FRIDAY.
BRIA